hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round six of
this year's Tata steel Masters Edition
it is Fabiana corvana versus gookish and
uh fabi's been having a great tournament
so far he has um a win in four draws and
gukashi could be having a better
tournament about okay it's uh pretty uh
pretty uh tough opposition here he got
three draws and two losses uh the losses
being to a ding in round one and to a
niche in round two and this game it's a
it's a really weird one you guys you
guys will definitely like it so let's
check it out Fabi with the white pieces
opens with D4 we have Knight to F6 uh C4
E6 Knight to F3 uh avoiding the nimzo
and now Pawn to D5 we have Knight the
Queen's Gambit declined with Knight to
C3 and now Bishop to B4 so the next best
thing as we usually say daragos in
defense and Black's been having a lot of
success with daragos and end with the
name so uh lately so it makes sense that
especially young players are choosing
such as such openings and the main ideas
here on how to challenge this are Bishop
to g5c captures on D5 Queen day for with
check also E3 can be played Queen to B3
is also possible but for the game Queen
day for check officially it's like the
third most popular continuation so of
course bookish knows how to tackle this
with Knight to C6 E3 and now a gookish
castles we have a queen to C2 as the
queen is no longer useful on this
diagonal and now Knight the e7a
interestingly uh this is uh like the
seventh most popular move in this
position but the engine really loves it
for some reason people just don't play
it
uh but Lucas obviously did a lot of work
on it and uh sorry and uh he goes for
Knight t7 not Knight to D7 Knight D7 uh
with Bishop to D2 now the Knight is no
longer pinned and pawn to B6 now
preparing to go after the C4 Pawn we
have A3 and now uh not retreating with
the bishop to allow something like V4
but rather B characters and C3 with
Bishop captures and now Bishop to A6
again stops B4 uh as the C4 Pawn is
hanging so we have Pawn to B3 and now
Rook the C8 preparing to advance the
pawn to C5 and there is a a game from
2016 between Boris grachu and Matthias
bluebound that reached this position
where Bishop to D3 was played and makes
sense it put puts pressure on the H7
Pawn also it stops Knight the E4 but
that's not what 5 played in this game
here five he played Rook to D1 and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and it's very
interesting how the game continues uh
because the difference uh a very obvious
one with the Rook to D1 and Bishop to D3
the one that bought his garage have
played is that white is not controlling
the E4 square and here Lucas could
definitely drop a knight to the E4 uh it
it would be very tricky for white to
handle this he goes after the bishop and
C3 and of course you don't want to give
up the bishop pair for nothing so we're
gonna Retreat it and now let's say you
strike in the center with C5 and now
he's Bishop to D3 uh one might even
consider Pawn to F5 and it's a very very
active position for black with the both
lights were in dark Square Bishop
currently of a very limited power but
okay in the game after Rook to D1 Lucas
started with C5 right away and you will
see how this is much much different than
the idea that we've just shown uh Fabi
plays D captures on C5 now he opens up
his dark Square Bishop Rook captures on
C5 and now Queen to B2 now putting
pressure on the Knight and F6 and it's
very tricky to deal with this if you
move the Knight you lose the G7 Pawn so
probably you should play something like
Knight the E8 but that just looks weird
another thing if you if you play
something like Knight to G6 so the queen
protects the Knight it's a bit of a more
active Square then you run into Bishop
B4 and your Rooks are now in trouble so
it's hard to say uh how one should go
about this but a gokish goes Queen to C8
it's a very weird move that gives up the
the G6 pawn and also allows Fabi to mess
up his Pawn structure so let's see what
Lucas had in mind here we have Bishop
captures and F6 by Fabi G captures Queen
captures and now just Knights the G6 now
getting ready to start capturing on C4
the idea is uh pretty clear uh fabi's
King is still on E1 and uh the king
could be a bit vulnerable there but Fabi
just starts the king side attack on the
H4
uh he wants to play Pawn to H5 then Pawn
to H6 and Checkmate the black king so
it's hard to say who is really attacking
here with d captures and C4 by gookish
now Ponte H5 uh we have rooked F5 you
have to get the Queen off of this
diagonal somehow Queen to C3 and now
Knight the E7 and uh the problem is you
cannot go for C captures on B3 there's
just too much stuff hanging if play C
captures on B3 of course just Queen
captures now the the bishop here will
also hang if you capture with the Rook
so you have to capture with the bishop
but now you just lose the Knight here
and uh even though the engine uh kind of
says that you really don't have uh all
that much better than this but Knight
the E7 is a little bit better of course
the move that bookish plays uh and now
Fabi plays B captures and C4 I will just
uh for fun show you a line
uh as this is a classical game uh that
starts with E4 and the point is uh the
Rook really should not move uh from uh
from this uh file you really don't want
to give up a control of F6 because Queen
to F6 and H6 uh just ended the game
black will get checkmated so we're gonna
place a something like Rook to F4 now
Queen to E3 you go after the rook and
after Queen C7 defense The Rook in G3
let's say Rook to G4 uh now we're gonna
play Bishop to E2 and just move the
Knight and continue harassing this Rook
so this is one way uh you could play
this it doesn't even matter if you trade
Queens here for example a queen captures
B capture is now just Knight to D2
attacks the rook and once The Rook moves
you're even gonna play Rook to H4 take
the G four square away from the black
rook and now play Knight to F3 once
again so there's really no good Square
for this Rook like let's say C3 black
wants to trade some pieces here you
don't care just Knight to F3 and now if
capture is attacking your Rook just King
captures The Rook is still hanging no
squares on the on the fifth rank for
that Rook so we're gonna have to go back
Rook to G7 now H6 Rook to G6 and okay
you get to keep the Rook but now the
pawns will start falling and it's a very
passive Square for The Rook
uh so after this Knight the E7 move uh
definitely something that Fabi could
have gone for he goes for B captures and
C4 and now bookish uh gets into the game
a little bit now Pawn to F6 and now you
no longer have to worry now if the Rook
is attacked you can move the Rook
anywhere and the F6 square is no longer
available for the White Queen uh so
Bishop to E2 we have rooked the C5 now
continuing to put pressure on this Pawn
uh Knight to D2 and now Bishop back to
B7 putting pressure on the G2 Pawn but
5B just plays the very nice Rook to F uh
Rook to H4 now Rook Bishop captures on
G2 is impossible due to Rook to G4 check
winning that Bishop so here Pawn to E5
by gookish uh and now Knight the E4 uh
the Knight is uh is a very nasty looking
Beast here also eyeing that D6 Square so
bookish captures it Bishop captures an
E4 we have Rook captures on e4 and now
Queen to E6 getting the queen into the
game also preparing moves like F5 here
five replace Queen to D2 and now Rook
the A5 going after the A3 Pawn Rook the
G4 check with King to F7 and now Pawn to
H6 preparing Queen to Rook to G7 check
and here Lucas played Knight the G6 but
there really aren't any better moves uh
of course you cannot go after the pawn
if you go after the pawn you get
checkmated that's very clear here you're
just gonna uh this will be met with the
queen 38 Checkmate uh but Lucas played
Knight the G6 he stopped this but now uh
Fabi has a very very nice winning idea
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find this move uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
wild brilliancy and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to C5 that's the good stuff clearing the
C4 Square for the white bishop and now
there really isn't all that much for
gukas to do if any of you uh aside from
C5 uh found Bishop to F3 uh then you are
you you're just uh much much stronger
than an uh you know a very strong Grand
Master not just a very strong
Grandmaster a former US champion a
former World chair Championship
Challenger uh like Bishop to F3 is so
strong that it's impossible to see why
it's good because okay you're
threatening Bishop D5 but look at this
King to E7 and now uh what's the what's
the idea how do you how do you continue
this Rook G3 now you want to clear the
G4 Square for the bishop black will play
F5 now he played Bishop to H5 this is so
weird uh that you you still don't
understand why why this is so good for
white Ponte F4 it seems like black black
is the one who's winning here but not
really just Rook G4 and I'll look at his
F captures f-captress and there's no
good move for black here whatever you
play you're just gonna get uh completely
destroyed but that's not a very human uh
thing to play uh so instead after this
Knight to G6 move five you just play
Pawn to C5 and this uh cannot be met
with anything now Rook captures on A3 of
course uh will be met with Bishop to C4
and now you just have to give up the
queen queen captures and C4 and now
let's equate to D7 check Knight D7 and
of course you don't pick up the queen
you deliver Checkmate that's the idea so
after C5 Lucas has to take back Rook
captures on C5 now he guards the C4
square but the real idea was Queen to D7
with check and now after Queen captures
on D7 Rook captures on D7 check was
played King to G8 and now Rook captures
on A7 uh also one of the reasons why
Fabi really wanted to get that that Rook
away from the a file but even uh you
don't have to play this like the
position is so strong you could even
play Rook to C4 seems like a weird move
to play but the position is so winning
for white you just don't care if Rook
captures Bishop captures if not you just
capture the rook and again you get the
C4 Square for your Bishop you cannot uh
block this you have to play King th8 now
just through a capture Sun A7 and you're
never getting out of this this is just
um I mean a such a passive position it's
absolutely terrible if the Rook ever
moves from the back rank uh the pawn
covers this the bishop covers this the
king is completely boxed in any
background check will be a back rank
Checkmate so instead after King to J the
road captures an A7 was played by Fabi
everything here is winning Rook the C1
check row King to D2 and now Rook the H1
going after that H6 spawn but now Fabi
just prepares to double up on the
seventh rank Rook to B4 uh Rook captures
an H6 Rook captures on B6 and now Rook
to H2 uh you if you tried to block with
Rook dev7 again you run into Bishop to
C4 so that's impossible so Rook the H2
was played but now just Rook B to B7 and
it was in this position unmove 36 that
uh gookish resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh there
there's really nothing to try like you
you could get out of check but it now
comes let's say Bishop to G4 and how are
you playing this you can never uh
capture on G2 because you get checkmated
Rook captures followed by the other road
going to G7 Checkmate and if something
like Rook to d8 with check you're just
gonna move the king and it Knight to f8
okay you control the H7 Pawn but just G3
now black is without any Targets if
Ponte for Bishop to F5 puts more
pressure here puts more pressure on e4
and if Rook d8 rooked F7 there's just
nothing to play here you're going after
this Pawn you will start advancing the a
pawn and okay could have prolonged this
but he knows that I mean this is just
self-torture he will just be suffering
for for no reason uh he can just rest up
for uh for the next game so yeah very
nicely done by Fabi uh getting his
second win uh in the tournament uh now
uh it's it's uh he's currently leading
in the tournament but some of the games
are of course still being in play like
Abdul sotros and Geary's so we'll see
what happens yesterday I kind of showed
you the wrong standings because lavon's
game was still in play uh so sorry about
that uh in the next video that I that I
uh cover about round six I will show you
the the precise standing so I really
sorry about that but yeah very nicely
done by Fabi again it's uh hard to say
but uh probably really confused him with
this Rook to D1 like Bishop to D3 seems
very natural you of course know what the
white is doing it's a very nice
developing move but Fabi just played
Rook to D1 and he kept his King in the
center of the board for the entire game
which sort of gave gave Lucas the
incentive uh to try and sacrifice a
little bit of material to go for the
attack but um like I said If instead of
the C5 move he just goes for night day
four it's a it's a completely different
game uh now like we said Bishop to A1 C5
and now is Bishop to D3 Now Pawn to F5
and this is much much different than
what what we saw in the game and
probably would have ended much much
different but yeah Rook to D1 always a
very tricky move ever since uh
Anderson's game uh but I always always
take care after Rook 8 the D1 is played
and even before it is played uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by Fabi I would like to
thank ravishing reptiles YouTube I love
Adrian and Jude easy ovens is the best
Derek King and Richard F sayash for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata steel until it finishes uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day